[Music]
we stay at home measure is now in place
for much of the country streets and
highways across the u.s. are eerily
clear of traffic right now but there's
at least one unexpected benefit from
that those empty roads mean truckers
jobs are getting a lot easier as more
american shift to working from home and
limit travel in and around their
communities trucking companies are
making heroic efforts to keep store
shelves stocked from toilet paper food
cleaning supplies everything that's run
low and they panic buying spurred by the
corona virus pandemic people were
concerned they started stockpiling food
I think people have talked about toilet
paper all these other items that people
are stockpiling it and sort of purchase
justing out of the idea of maybe not
being on the by that in the future if
they can to their homes and so we saw
really big spikes in the demand for
trucking and Freight in parts of the
country going through that and for
specific categories like food and
beverage you know home sanitation Goods
personal goods things like that you know
when you sit around and hang out with
people and talk about things that are
frustrating traffic product comes up
pretty frequently it's like a common
thing I think right now people are
talking about how there is no traffic
and so trucks are definitely able to get
places faster so if you combine both the
you know average speeds on the highway
as well as the increase in in hours of
service there's more capacity right now
to do stuff around the country
TRUCKING giant JB Hunt is providing a
one time bonus of $500 for its drivers
and personnel at field operations and
customer facilities in recognition of
how hard they're working right now
driving the truck moving things around
in the warehouse getting things staged
and prepared at the docks for the truck
to show up last mile delivery to
someone's home you know I don't know if
most consumers have change their online
buying habits but I think what you're
seeing is a massive strain on the supply
chain Amazon has is obviously and many
other companies are now delivering
products more slowly because they can't
obviously meet the two-day delivery
window and there's so many other
important products that need to be
delivered and I don't think people or
necessary looking at whether or not they
should be making this purchases and how
much strain they put in the supply chain
every time they order something
everything they buy something and life
has changed for all those drivers the
truck stops they rely on for fuel food
groceries or just a break from the road
have also had to scale back some
services indoor dining has been
suspended fitness facilities that big
truck stops are shut down and
much-needed showers although still
available or in tight supply due to more
extensive cleaning due to the virus on
the one hand you know if truck drivers
and warehouse workers and other people
in splicing start to get sick and it
really starts to disrupt the supply
chain that will have a big impact if the
kind of stockpiling slows down and that
wave passes that'll have another big
impact it'll change kind of the velocity
of frame right now you know if we see
the economy slowed down and businesses
slow down for not just a month but for
three months or manufacturing stops for
a quarter then that's gonna have a
really big impact as well so we don't
know exactly how big the impact of each
of these factors will be we don't know
how far east them will go but we do know
there's really big changes happening
right now and there's gonna be some some
you know probably a bunch of surprises
over the next few months for everyone
this country
in the near term there's a little
indication circumstances will improve as
experts warn that the US hasn't yet felt
the full impact of the kovat 19 crisis
but trucking companies like JP huntin
order enterprises in Omaha Nebraska have
an army of drivers across the u.s. doing
everything they can to make sure that
supermarkets remain stocked oh and if
you need a job
Werner CEO Derek leathers says his
company still needs more high-quality
drivers and he's hiring
[Music]